[Music]
ashley is with us in dallas hi ashley
how are you
hi i'm okay how are you
better than i deserve what's up kiddo
good thank you um
i am calling i'm gonna try to keep this
as clear as i can i'm in a bit of a
complicated situation
um but i just found out that
about three weeks ago
that i am
expecting a child yay this would be my
first
thank you
um
however it
is
um
i the person that you know would be the
father would be my ex-husband
um
and um
i'm not
sure at this moment if he will be
around
um
you know he's being very
unclear about that
apparently he was around recently
yeah
yeah definitely
yeah
yeah it's crazy um but i mean he says
that he i mean i'm not getting that he's
opposed to it he says he's okay with it
at the same time he's not really talking
to me
um how old are you i'm just confused
i am 34
he is 42.
do you have a job
does he have a job yes do you have other
children from the marriage
no no okay
how long have you been divorced
um
about three and a half years okay
yeah how much do you how much do you
make a year honey
me um well i have a disability so i'm
doing like maybe 17 000
before taxes a year because i can't
really work too much what is the nature
of your disability
um so i have multiple sclerosis so i
have some mobility issues
and
um vision a little bit
i'm just kind of a myriad of things
um you got family you got family in the
area
um i have
my adopted mom she's kind of close ish
she's about an hour away from me
so that's all i really have
in that regard
but
i'm just kind of lost because i don't
know
how to prepare for this financially
i'm i understand i'm gonna probably need
to change some things living situation
wise because i live in a very
small apartment that's only 324 square
feet i have a very small car it's like a
small like a smart car
and i just got told it probably will
need a new engine so
i'm going to have to replace that and i
just don't know how i'm gonna do all of
this financial wise especially with the
rent being like it is and the car prices
being the way that they are
um i just don't know how i'm gonna do
this and prepare for this child
financially especially if i may have to
do it alone
so and i don't really know exactly yet
but um
um
there's so much going on here i'm so
sorry
that's a scary scary situation you find
yourself in
okay so
what i would
tell my best friend if they called and
told me the exact thing you told me
is i would tell them that you need to
get people in your corner as much as
possible that's why i was asking about
friend
our family i i would
[Music]
definitely start working on the career
side of your equation find something
that you're able to do that makes a lot
more money that is within the tolerance
of your ms uh ms is as i understand is
aggravated by stress so you can't be in
a high stress scenario but you're
getting ready to be and i stress you're
getting ready to be in a stressful
financial situation if you don't create
some more income so you have to create
some more income
i would uh uh
do do you belong to or have you visited
or are you aware of a local church in
your area that you respect
um
well i've been going to a church online
um which one it's not really in my area
okay um
yeah it's in oklahoma um but i know of
one
that's in the area that i can
you know get connected with i want you
to get connected so you've got emotional
support
and when they know what you're going
through maybe even some financial
support temporarily while you get your
income up and you make a transition to
different living in different vehicle
but don't do any of it with debt because
that's going to bring you down further
we got to get your income up and make
these moves
right yeah yeah but you've got you're
going to have to have some people around
you
that are walking with you and are
supporting you
um emotionally financially relationally
everything because you're
you're kind of by yourself out here on a
limb and you're scared
right yeah yeah that's exactly what i
feel right now i'm like i feel like i
was
you know i'm
almost basically out of debt i only have
like 150 left on a medical loan my
student loan was discharged so that's
another thing that is kind of hindering
me on the income side but
well it can still be discharged you've
been permanently you've been declared
permanently disabled the student loan is
gone it doesn't come back
if you go get a job it doesn't come back
and so you you've got the rest of your
life to live and create an income and 17
000 isn't a good life
so we need to work on this income side
of the equation long term for you and
for the baby
lastly while you're at that church ask
um the folks there if there is an
attorney there that could give you some
advice
i'm not an expert on the law in texas
but in most states
your
ex-husband is going to be responsible
for child
support whether he wants to be involved
or not
legally
in most states a percentage of his
income will go to raise the child
that he caused to come into the world
and i don't really care whether he likes
it or not i'm not really taking a poll
here of his feelings
i'm worried about one thing and that's
the child
yeah no thank you i appreciate that
because i i was like i don't know what
my
my rights are since you know this is
new you know and i'm not sure what your
rights are either but i suspect your due
child support that's my suspicion
yeah and so i would you know and i think
you're probably gonna have to get uh
someone to help you at least coach you a
little bit on the legal side so you can
have this discussion with him and he can
do this voluntarily or will have a judge
instruct him to do it whichever he
prefers
yeah
yeah i hope that we can work that out
but no thank you yeah and i i think
so here's the here's what i think i'm
saying
i think if you have some family support
some community and church support
and some money coming from the father
and you start to adjust your income in
your life living situation in your car
situation by the time you make all those
adjustments this is all going to be okay
but you're going to need all of those
things bringing to bear on the problem
yeah
i'm so sorry you're going through this
ashley let us know if we can help down
the line as you sort through this and
figure out what the next steps are but
uh that's a real tough thing to be
walking through and you've got to have
those people in your corner so i love
the idea of you plugging into a local
church
yeah so hang on kelly i'll pick up and
we're going to get you signed up for
financial peace university online so you
can go through the class
and get in the every dollar app that'll
help you manage the money as you
increase your income from child support
and from a changed career you'll be able
to manage that because your income is
getting ready to double or triple by the
time we finish with all these things
here
should anyway
and so we got to get you to 34 maybe to
45 000 but time all the smoke clears on
this
and um you know you've also got to
investigate uh you know what your
uh medical insurance situation is uh for
the labor and delivery and start
preparing for that as well but we'll
walk with you we're here in your corner
if you get scared and you need some more
help you call us anytime hon
wow